Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel
just revealed they're introducing the sentry
in the MCU through the Thunderbolts movie so I'll
explain what's going on and how the origin of the
MCU Sentry is connected to what Thunderbolt
Ross is doing the weapons plus program the
super soldier serum and the Thunderbolts team
itself because most of them are super soldiers
like there's a lot of super soldier stuff going
on in the Thunderbolts movie so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'll do more Sentry videos more
Thunderbolts videos as we get more details and
footage from the movie but it's basically like the
MCU introducing its version of homelander someone
who's totally crazy and nigh and vulnerable with
crazy levels of power big thank you to today's
sponsor vessi shoes keeping my feet nice and
comfortable that's why they're my go-to at the
gym doing errands going to the beach when I'm
pretending like I went on vacation but secretly
I'm still running around doing work seriously I
haven't been on a vacation in like six years
they're built for everyday life in perfect in
all weather they keep your feet warm and dry
when it's cold and raining they're waterproof
snow proof since we're heading into winter season
they're incredibly comfortable breathable they fit
like a sock they have sizes and styles for the
entire family and their grip is designed for all
weather so you can wear them whether you're out
hiking in the woods just doing errands and they
look great so make them your go-to shoes they're
currently having a Black Friday sale and they're
giving away a pair of Free socks of your choice
for the first hundred people to purchase a pair of
shoes you can use my code emergency awesome or the
link they gave me vessi dot com slash emergency
awesome I'll put the link on screen here and down
in the description below so be sure to go check
them out the reason why we're talking about the
Sentry is because you probably saw in your feeds
this week that Marvel revealed they're casting an
evil Superman character from the comics to be one
of the villains of the Thunderbolts movie if not
the main villain they're kind of doing that thing
where they say that somebody is the main villain
but secretly somebody else is actually the villain
like Thunderbolt Ross is really like the big
antagonist of the MCU during Marvel Phase 5 Val is
another good example kind of an anti here but also
kind of one of the big antagonists of Marvel phase
five we got a couple teasers for what's going on
with that during black panther wakanda forever
with the Val the Thunderbolt Ross vibranium plot
we also learned that they just recast Harrison
Ford in the MCU as Thunderbolt Ross and will
turn him into Red Hulk during Captain America
four which comes out right before the Thunderbolts
movie so all this stuff were the Thunderbolts the
Sentry is meant to be connected when you hear
evil Superman in the MCU there are a couple of
main characters that come to mind mostly Sentry
and Hyperion they're two completely different
characters completely different backstories
Hyperion isn't Eternal like the ones we just
saw in the eternals movie with the same backstory
as Superman from DC like he was fired from his
dying planet to planet Earth and uses crazy
eternal's powers to become a more hardcore
anti-superman kind of character within the ranks
of Marvel's heroes and villains in Squadron
Supreme like that's his big team his version
of an anti-justice League kind of like Marvel's
version of the boys 7 team Sentry is also like
Marvel's version of Superman with the twist that
he's totally schizophrenic Nick he's a schizotypal
personality disorder not the same thing that Moon
Knight suffers from but similar both of them have
alternate personalities like Moon Knight has Mark
Spector Stephen Grant we just made Jake lockley at
the end of that series but he has something called
dissociative identity disorder which is different
from what Sentry has Sentry's real name is Robert
Reynolds he started out as a drug addict who was
just down in his luck and broke into a lab where
he thought he could find a Score he took what he
thought was going to be drugs that were going to
get him high but it wound up giving him Powers
it wound up being the golden sentry serum which
was a derivative of the super soldier serum part
of the weapons plus program it gave him the power
of a million exploding Suns like that version of
the super soldier serum was way more potent than
the version that the other super soldiers on the
Thunderbolts team got or even Captain America got
but the process of getting all that power when he
was already kind of broken mentally caused him to
develop an alternate personality called the void
who's a totally evil version of himself with an
equal level of power but different types of powers
I'll get us through this just as long as you
me stick together I love and a mommy and a daddy
you know so a lot of his backstory is similar to
the backstory for homelander and the other boys
superhero characters getting their powers from
compound V soldier boy is a good example like he's
the first version of the compound V superheroes
that they created eventually they refined the
formula like they did for the sentry in homelander
winds up getting a much more potent version of
it becoming nigh invulnerable the most powerful
person on planet Earth but the whole pitch is
that he's mentally very broken in character he's
not mentally stable so the whole idea is what if
Superman but he's totally crazy which is where you
get to the sentry in the MCU you think you look
strong you're just a cheap knock off... oh no...
I'm the upgrade the reason why I say the mystery
evil Superman that Marvel's introducing is Sentry
and not Hyperion is because of what Kevin feige
said at d23 the Thunderbolts presentation they
revealed what's going on with Val Thunderbolt
Ross and their whole plot to recreate super
soldiers in the weapons plus program this pays
off a long-running Easter egg that I'll explain
in a second from the first Incredible Hulk movie
and at d23 Kevin feige very specifically remarked
that Winter Soldier was going to be the most
mentally stable person on the Thunderbolts David
Harbor who plays Red Guardian said it's all about
this group of fundamentally broken people mentally
broken that is who have crazy levels of powers
who find a way to work together and help heal
each other slowly like help each other actually
accomplish their mission but also fix a lot of
their mental problems they've been suffering from
and a lot of them just happen to be super soldiers
kind of like Sentry is technically he's a super
soldier even though it's a slightly different
version of the formula through Captain America
4 and the Thunderbolts movie they're paying off
this long-running Easter egg from The Incredible
Hulk movie with the weapons Plus program which is
meant to be Thunderbolt Ross's renamed version of
the super soldier program you're aware that we've
got an infantry weapons development program
well in WW2 they initiated a sub program
for biotech Force enhancement a super soldier and
I dusted it off got him doing serious work again
bold work so for example Wolverine comes from
the weapon x program but X is a Roman numeral
that stands for 10. he's the 10th version of the
weapons plus program of them trying to recreate
a super soldier using different means all the
members of the team here come from some iteration
of the weapons plus program or some offshoot
in the case of the Winter Soldier with hydra's
Winter Soldier program even though the Abomination
wasn't with them on stage here I think he'll also
be involved in the plot in some way he also got
a version of that super soldier serum Thunderbolt
Ross's whole thing with continuing the weapons
plus program during The Incredible Hulk movie and
then into present day it'll use to create more
super soldiers better weapons that he wants to
use to defend the United States from other future
threats like Thanos the program that Bruce Banner
was working on when he had his gamma accident
giving him his Hulk powers was secretly part
of the weapons plus program Thunderbolt Ross just
tricked him into working on it thinking that the
program was meant for something else and because
he got his powers in the US military's lab like
all the equipment that he was using when he became
the Hulk belonged to the US military Thunderbolt
Ross thinks of the Hulk as the property of the
U.S government and intends on taking that power
for himself to become Red Hulk I've already done
a much larger Red Hulk video explaining the actual
process of how he became Red Hulk in the comics
and how they're changing that for the movies so
we'll link that at the end of this and down in the
description below the reason why this is connected
to the origin of the sentry in the MCU is because
Sentry also got his powers from a derivative of
the super soldier serum weapons plus program
in the comic Sentry came from the same place
Deadpool came from called Department K which was
an offshoot of the weapon x program The Wolverine
program which itself was a further version of the
weapons plus program so the Sentry's origin is
meant to be very similar to homelander's origin a
lot of the other boys characters like Soldier Boy
started out as a dirt bag or were broken people
mentally and just got god-tier powers he's meant
to be one of the most powerful characters in the
Marvel Universe during World War Hulk for example
there's a bit of world war Hulk plot that they're
using for Captain America 4 in the Thunderbolts
movie it seems like he was able to fight World
breaker Hulk to a standstill with the fight just
going on until they eventually wore each other
out because neither one could kill each other
but even though they say he has the power of a
million exploding Sons his actual Powers go Way
Beyond Superman types of powers he has molecule
manipulation super speed flight immortality he
can heal people extreme regeneration faster
than Deadpool and Wolverine's regeneration
nigh invulnerability telepathy he can create
force fields shape-shifting energy manipulation
weather manipulation in the comics the way they
introduce his character is in a rashimon kind of
story where he just wakes up confused in present
day this kind of overweight middle-aged man not
really understanding what's going on but slowly
remembering who he is he's sentry he has all
these god-tier Powers eventually he learns that in
order to protect the world from his evil Persona
the void he caused the entire world to forget
about the Sentry including himself it was a way
for Marvel to explain how he was created by factor
in the 1950s 1960s and had been alive this entire
time while you're having all these adventures with
the Avengers all these big crossovers but you're
only learning about the Sentry in the early 2000s
when they first introduced the character nobody
knew about him because they pulled a Spider-Man
no way home it was just like the movie Just cost
everybody on the planet to forget about the
Sentry at least until he remembered everything
which caused the evil Persona within his mind
to resurface the void bringing that threat back
as well so the whole idea is so unpredictable
so crazy that it's even harder to deal with him
as a character and get him to do what you want
than it is to deal with a version of the full
Hulk like the Mindless Hulk so the idea during the
Thunderbolts movie is that you have this mentally
unstable team of anti-heroes trying to take down
or talk down the Sentry in insurmountable nigh
and vulnerable and totally crazy Force so part of
the whole joke here part of the pitch is that they
have zero chance against him like there's no way
that they'd be able to stop him he's that powerful
in faced with that how do they wind up taking him
down or talking him down down talking him back to
his senses and a lot of this is about getting
over past trauma and dealing with your mental
problems they kind of addressed that during Falcon
and Winter Soldier with Winter Soldiers character
being in therapy and slowly working through his
problems so right now my early theory is is they
have to face the sentry there's no way they can
beat him and they won't beat him they'll find a
way to talk him back to his senses the actors
that they're supposedly looking out for the
role right now are Ryan Gosling and Alexander
Skarsgard either one would be great I'm sure
whoever they find will be a lot of fun but if
they're introducing a Sentry let me know what
else you want them to do with the character in the
future obviously we're just talking about the end
of Marvel Phase 5 Marvel phase six is Avengers
5 Kane Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret Wars so this is
still like a whole other phase after they would
introduce the character I'm still working on my
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special review
that'll be my next video to post make sure to
enable alerts from my channel so you don't miss
that everyone click here to learn about the
secret Deadpool Christmas movie that Ryan Reynolds
made and click here to learn what's going on with
Thor 5 thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!